คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมถูกออกแบบมาเพื่อแก้ปัญหา ที่คอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกทำไม่ได้
ไม่ว่าจะเป็นการค้นหาวัสดุที่ใช้
ในการดักจับคาร์บอนเพื่อ
รับมือกับการเปลี่ยนแปลงสภาพภูมิอากาศ
หรือการพัฒนาปุ๋ยที่มีประสิทธิภาพมากขึ้น
ที่ไม่ทำลายโลก แต่ยังช่วยให้
ห่วงโซ่อุปทานอาหารยังคงดำเนินต่อไปได้
เพื่อเลี้ยงดูประชากรโลก
นอกจากนี้ยังมีคำถามพื้นฐานเกี่ยวกับจักรวาลของเรา
ว่ามันประกอบกันอย่างไร และสสารมีพฤติกรรมอย่างไรในระดับอะตอม
และระดับต่ำกว่าอะตอมที่เราต้องการรู้
นี่คือพรมแดนถัดไป
มาดูหนึ่งในงานวิจัยที่กำลังดำเนินอยู่
การค้นหาแบตเตอรี่ชนิดใหม่
แบตเตอรี่เปลี่ยนชีวิตเราไปมากด้วยการทำให้เราพกพา
คอมพิวเตอร์และสมาร์ทโฟนได้
แต่ยังมีอะไรอีกมาก แบตเตอรี่มีความสำคัญ
ต่ออนาคตพลังงานสะอาดของเรา
ไม่ว่าจะเป็นการขับเคลื่อนรถยนต์ไฟฟ้า
หรือการผลักดันพลังงานหมุนเวียน
เราต้องการเคมีที่แตกต่างออกไปอย่างพื้นฐาน
เพื่อสร้างแบตเตอรี่
แห่งอนาคต การคำนวณควอนตัม
จะช่วยให้เรามองเข้าไปข้างในแบตเตอรี่ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
ระหว่างปฏิกิริยาที่ซับซ้อนมาก เพื่อช่วยให้เรา
คิดเกี่ยวกับวัสดุชนิดใหม่
และโครงสร้างของแบตเตอรี่ที่จะต้องนำมาใช้
เพื่อขับเคลื่อนอุปกรณ์ยุคหน้า
แล้วเราจะไปถึงจุดนั้นได้อย่างไร ด้วยการสร้างอุปกรณ์ควอนตัมที่ล้ำที่สุดในโลก
และแพลตฟอร์มสำหรับพัฒนา
และเปิดให้โลกใช้งาน
มีเพียงการร่วมมือกันตั้งแต่ตอนนี้
เท่านั้นที่จะทำให้เราแก้ปัญหาที่กำลังจะเผชิญ
ร่วมกันในอนาคตได้